es geht um das thema flüchtlinge um das
thema als siemens gab heute einen großen
knatsch ein knatsch bei den ampel
koalitionsverhandlungen es geht um das
thema
asylbewerberleistungen ein ganz
schwieriges wort aber dahinter verbirgt
sich viel es geht um die frage wie
sollen asylbewerber künftig in
deutschland behandelt werden welche
leistungen bekommen sie auf was für
leistungen haben sie ein anrecht unter
möchten die grünen einen deutlichen
verbesserung sie möchten dieses gesetz
abschaffen und sie möchten asylbewerber
quasi den bundesbürgern direkt
gleichstellen das hat für empörung
gesorgt unter anderem bei der fdp und
jetzt ist die große frage wie umgehen
denn wir sehen ja ohnehin deutschland
ist ein land das ein magnet ist für
menschen die aus anderen ländern zu uns
kommen wollen die hier leben wollen die
hier einen asylantrag stellen und
deswegen mein appell das
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz muss bleiben
ist darf keine verbesserung geben für
die asylbewerber die ohnehin hier viele
viele leistungen bekommen wir brauchen
in deutschland diesbezüglich keine
änderung stoppt die grünen plänen
jan also klar wir wollen jetzt kein
magnet werden aber wir sind doch ein
magnet vor allem weil es den menschen in
anderen europäischen ländern schlechter
geht da verstehe ich schon die grünen
die sagen warum müssen wir uns jetzt den
nachkredit nach den griechen nach den
rumänen nach dem bulgaren ausrichten
oder nachdem denen die jetzt
abschiebelager errichten wo es drinnen
schimmelt wo die toiletten schmutzig
sind also müsste haben wir nicht die
aufgabe und selbst nach den eigenen
standards genauso um jeden punkt geht es
auch nichts geht nicht darum etwas
abzusenken das ist richtig da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch gesagt
dass es gar nicht möglich es gibt ein
existenzminimum das muss auch in
deutschland gelten es geht eher darum
noch was drauf zu satteln also zum
beispiel 200.000 abgelehnte asylbewerber
aber dann hier einfach die bisher
geduldet werden im land zu belassen ihn
quasi einen richtigen aufenthaltsstatus
zu geben es geht darum dass asylbewerber
künftig auch schneller eingebürgert
werden können dass sie vom ersten tag an
wo sie hier sind bereits den kompletten
rundum schutz bei gesundheit bei
sozialleistungen erhalten diese punkte
geht es und das sollten wir menschen die
schneller einbürgern die sich hinter
green können es geht am ende gibt's ja
eine sogwirkung also eine sogwirkung
nach deutschland wir stellen fest diese
sogwirkung gibt es bereits und warum
soll man diese sogwirkung durch
beispielsweise soziale leistungen
zusätzlich verbessern wurden ist das ein
punkt den die cdu genauso sieht wie die
grünen möglicherweise also dass sie sagt
dann muss noch draufgesattelt werden
nein dass sie die cdu komplett anders
bin froh dass die fdp dort gemacht hat
wir wissen doch schauen wir sehen dann
den ganzen asylpolitik das versagen der
europäischen union ist keine sache der
nationalstaaten die frage allein zu
erklären dass wir diese unterschiedliche
standards haben nicht doch daran dass
jedes land für sich die entscheidung
trifft auch nach den maßstäben der
rechtsprechung war die europäische union
die eigentlich zuständig ist ihre
außengrenzen zu schützen ihre abkommen
einzuhalten dass sie völlig versagt und
das schon seit einigen jahren und das
ist das verheerende situation wenn die
ampel koalition was machen will dann
muss ihre stimme in europa erhoben und
muss dafür sorgen dass europäische union
endlich ein einheitliches asylrecht auf
den weg bringt die gleichen standards
und gleichen regeln für alle ja weil als
partei ist doch seit jahren an der macht
ihre partei stellt doch das feld noch
immer so weit ich weiß das
bundeskanzleramt warum haben sie sich
denn nicht mal engagiert den letzten
fünf sechs jahren damit die eu das
hinkriegt dass auch immer leicht auf die
eu nach brüssel zu schieben aber lesen
sie doch in hat ja zu recht die letzten
jahre sich sehr intensiv bemüht als sie
hat den auch grenzen gesehen in der
europäischen union auch jetzt zuletzt
beim gipfel wurden keine einigung in
diesen fragen erzielt werden kann osten
muss das bestreben jeder deutschen
bundesregierung seien die gerade cdu
geführt oder künftig geführt dass diese
aufgabe europäischen union gelöst wird
sonst geht das nicht auf wenn wir
tatsächlich hier an unseren weiteren
standards noch mehr zur einladung
umfunktionieren dann belasten wir
erstens die aufnahmeländer an den
europäischen außengrenzen die markieren
ja zu recht ihre probleme weil sie sagen
ihr löst nicht die kommen alle zu uns
plötzlich haben wir die belastung und
deswegen ist die solidarische leistung
in deutschland auch die den anderen an
den außengrenzen zu helfen indem wir
nicht weiter an unseren gesetzen herum
werk es wird genug getan 1000 grenzen
was soll denn da getan werden wollen wir
dass dazu ein mauern gebaut werden
wollen wir dass das militär aufgefahren
wird wollen wir dass die grenzen die
wenn man sich die ganze ostgrenze der eu
betrachtet tausende von kilometern lang
ist von militär bewacht wird das kann
nicht die lösung sein die lösung sind
politische mittel und was die ostgrenze
angeht muss man dann mit moskau reden
das ist keine frage von minsk sondern
von moskau als wirklich von weißrussland
sondern von russland und putin wird wie
gut das klappt das haben wir sehen in
sachen ukraine also das ja natürlich und
den wunderbaren mara villa magen wenn
man
jetzt ich weiß im wievielten ja die
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland
aufrechterhält in der fiktion das jemals
die krim wieder zurückgegeben würde dann
hat man natürlich keine oder nur eine
schmale gesprächsgrundlage da muss man
mal grundsätzlich bilanz ziehen über die
deutsch russischen beziehungen oder
europäisch russischen beziehungen ich
will nur zur frage aufnahme von
flüchtlingen sagen der schwerpunkt ist
ja ganz anderer muss man ganz anders an
den nächsten jahren dieses land braucht
arbeitskräfte aus dem ausland und zwar
sehr viele die bundesanstalt für arbeit
spricht von 400.000 pro jahr die
zuwandern müssen da muss man da haben
sie völlig recht herb ihr dorf da muss
man diejenigen übernehmen die hiermit
geduldeten status leben und das schon
erfüllen die bedingungen die haben ja
viel handarbeit absolut was sie hat noch
unternehmerin fragen haben die planen
immer sendern aber gucken wie kriegt man
andere leute hier und da war deutschland
immer zu pingelig und hat nicht genug
angebote gemacht und die leute schlecht
behandelt turniers wie es nicht ich
glaube das ist kein problem das wir
jetzt letzten jahren erst 2015 haben das
ganz haben wir seit den 60ern dass wir
einfach arbeitsstabs verhängen die leute
nicht integrieren lassen nicht arbeiten
lassen und das muss aufhören bei
ansonsten fördern wir auch hier wieder
nur eine zwei klassen gesellschaft die
die meiner meinung nach gar nicht mehr
contemporary oder gegenwärtig herrschen
muss ich bin da sehr bei herrn piaf wenn
wir sagen wir dürfen die leute auch
jetzt gleich immigrieren hierher und die
haben dann eine vollständige sozialen
status können sich beliebig 99 berufen
orientieren dass das sollte die maxime
sein und ich glaube die problematik mit
grenzen mit militär- oder mit polizei
gewalt schützen das haben wir während
der korona krise an der bayerischen
grenze gesehen das hat einfach nicht
funktioniert weil wir wanderbewegungen
alltäglich haben aber wieder alles dass
das problem bei dieser garten asyl und
flüchtlingspolitik wir brauchen
zuwanderung arbeitsmarkt mit fachkräften
ja gar ein flüchtling ein sehr
glücklicher ist genau zweiter punkt ist
wir müssen uns um die kümmern die schon
lange da sind die die voraussetzungen
erfüllen das ist sozusagen dieser
spurwechsel debatte die unterschiedlich
geführt wird ich bin eher dafür in
meiner partei ist noch welche dagegen
aber ich finde da einer sozusagen
rechtssicherheit zu schaffen in den
leuten auch eine perspektive zu geben
die zweite punkt dritte punkt es ist ein
klares asylrecht haben jeder hat einen
anspruch dass er asyl verfahren geprüft
wird
aber eben das ist geprüft wird und das
heißt auch wenn abgelehnt wird wird
abgeschoben und der straffällig wird
wird abgeschoben und werden anspruch
aufrecht der wo es dann schnell
integriert werden der muss sprachfähig
gemacht werden da muss auf den
arbeitsmarkt integriert werden muss die
möglichkeiten haben sich hier in unserer
gesellschaft auch ein zu finden und dann
kommt dazu dass er eben auch schauen
müssen was machen wir denen die gar
nicht integrationswillig sind in
thüringen ist gerade aktuell dieser fall
aufgekommen dass afghanischer
flüchtlinge eine ganze kirche leer
geräumt hat weil er mit dem christlichen
glauben nichts anfangen kann ist in die
kirche gang hat alles ausgeräumt und der
fahrer stand da und hat war geschockt
was da passiert ist ich glaube diese
dinge muss man ordnet wenn wir das
ordentlich macht dann gibt es auch
verständnis bei den leuten aber genau
das ist der punkt glaube ich an mohring
den sie auch machen diese unterscheidung
über das asylrecht oder das recht auf
asyl für politisch verfolgte über das
wird ja gar nicht debattiert das steht
außer frage es gibt eigentlich um den
fall des zuzugs von menschen die hierher
kommen wollen weil sie sich hier mehr
hoffnung auf ein besseres leben erwarten
dass an der migration über jene ich darf
es nicht geben
wir in der tat dann etwas zwar jene die
den arbeitsmarkt möglicherweise die für
den arbeitsmarkt vielleicht gar nicht
verfügbar sind bzw gar nichts bringen
das ist ja ein dritter punkt zu sagen
wir haben beispielsweise ein
punktesystem und das wollen die grünen
auch und die fdp auch da kann man
sicherlich sehr engagiert auch dann
positiv drüber reden also dass man sich
aussucht wir wollen den zahnarzt wir
brauchen den bauarbeiter den it-experten
so dass aber ein anders die locke ich
auch nicht mit einem guten sozialsystem
automatisch sondern die lok ich dann mit
einem guten job und mit guten löhnen
aber hier geht es um den anderen punkt
hier geht es darum eigentlich er das
signal zu senden kommt auch anderen wir
wissen auch gibt eine große studie der
us-universität princeton die ganz klar
herausgefunden hat das ist eine
sogwirkung natürlich gibt wenn man die
sozialleistungen zu stark hochschraubt
also das ist ein klarer punkt und hier
versuchen die grünen offenbar ist das
vermischt sich im moment sehr viel was
die zuwanderung über die ostgrenzen
angeht es kommen afghanen die kommen
nicht aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
sondern die fliehen vor den taliban die
allermeisten jedenfalls dann kommen
iraker
junge männer überwiegend die aus nach
meiner wahrnehmung aus wirtschaftlichen
gründen kommen denn im irak gibt es
keinen bürgerkrieg mehr als gibt also
keinen richtigen druck zu fliehen und in
es ist auch eine frage ob es da noch
einen solchen bürgerkriegs druck gibt
der leute zwingt zu fliehen da bin ich
aber vorsichtig weil der wütet der
geheimdienstler ist das regime hinterher
da kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass
leute noch aus politischer not fliehen
ich finde es jetzt mal zeit wenn so eine
neue regierung ins amt kommt dass ich
ein paar neue instrumente überlegt wie
man
ausgebildete menschen aus dem ausland
nach deutschland holt die hier gebraucht
werden der wirtschaft und wie man mit
denen die einen duldungsstatus haben mal
einen strich drunter zieht und
diejenigen die man hier behalten will
weil sie hier arbeiten sich integriert
haben ausgebildet in den job haben die
lässt man hier und die anderen die das
nicht sind müssen das land wieder
verlassen und dann kann man auf einer
neuen grundlage des größenordnung würde
helfen